can welcome in to another edition of
Market takes I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you are here
with me and I appreciate that I'm Dion
rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal today we are digging into the
latest existing home sales report
talking about and explaining what's
going on with the housing market right
now existing home sales we know we're
about 80 percent of the overall housing
market so as we talk through this report
we're going to talk through the big
picture in housing we're going to talk
about what the report said obviously and
how that compared to expectations uh
then we're going to talk about how this
fit with other recent housing reports
we've seen we talked a little bit about
this on Monday's look ahead uh looking
forward to this week's data we're going
to talk about how this fits with the
current inflation narrative take a
little look at what's going on the
markets and then talk about what comes
next because this report and how it fits
into everything else that's going on is
going to tell us some important things
about what's going on with the economy
and also what's going on with the
overall housing market so let's get into
that first things first I want to talk
about today's report and what the report
said so want to throw up here a chart on
your screen so you can just see for
yourself what we've got going on in the
markets now as you see there are those
last four reports you see there was a
clear Trend moving downward and then the
numbers started to pick up and those
bars get a little bit higher as we moved
into 2023. so for May you saw 4.3
million homes sold that's that last bar
there on your screen existing home sales
Rose 0.2 percent they were expected to
drop 0.9 so economists were expecting
that declining Trend that we had seen
coming into this year to pick up again
and we had seen those two reports in a
row come in negative but this really
reverses that Trend and we saw home
sales rise slightly we also saw prices
rise just a little bit to 396 000 the
average existing home sold for about 396
thousand dollars up from 395 000 a month
ago now one thing that you wanna that
you're gonna hear a lot about from folks
is this was the biggest one-year drop
since 2011 but if you look up there on
your screen and you go back about a year
get to the middle that 2022 number well
you see those those charts are where
those bars are isn't really that
difference the decline was in prices and
the decline in terms of number of sales
wasn't that great so this chart really
just illustrating that we are seeing
again a pickup in the pick in the number
of views home sold or the number of
existing homes sold and we are not
seeing the continuation of that
declining number that was what the FED
wants to see we'll get into why the FED
wants to see that in just a moment when
we talk about prices right there was the
biggest drop in prices since 2011.
that's what I was referring to a little
bit earlier the biggest year-over-year
drop in prices but that year-over-year
drop in prices was from 408 396 000.
think about it if you're going out to
buy a home that's not a big difference
it's only about a 3.1 percent drop it's
just because generally speaking home
prices have not declined since 2011 very
much so a 3.1 percent drop is the
biggest drop we've seen since 2011 that
should just tell you listen that's not
really a big deal and that's
year-over-year decline so in one year
prices drop 3.1 percent you kind of
shrug that off if you're someone who's
thinking about buying a home or if
you're someone who's thinking about
selling a home that really doesn't
matter to you the momentum stalling out
here really suggests that we could have
hit a floor now what the FED wants is
for home sales to continue to drop
because it makes rent prices drop uh
with those higher rates with higher
rates of about double where they were a
little more than a year ago or a year
and a half ago there is an expectation
that you're going to see you know home
sales falling off a cliff that hasn't
happened they've declined a lot from
those huge highs from those big highs we
saw in 2021 and into 2022 but it's not
you're not seeing it fall off a cliff
we're still above 4 million sales per
month so that's a big that's a big deal
also the decline in the number of homes
sold year over year seems to be
flattening out now this is 20 percent
lower than the number of homes that were
sold a year ago but again that trend is
flattening so in May 2022 uh it's about
there's about 20 percent less home sold
in May 23 than there were in May 22 but
that's about the same as the previous
three months you saw a 23 decline the
month before 22.1 percent the month
before and 23.1 percent decline the
month before that all that to say it was
just rocketing lower you saw declines
each month getting bigger and bigger
down to a 37 year-over-year drop at the
beginning of the year in January and
that's reverse course and now we're only
about a 20 drop so again it's lower
there are less sales certainly but the
decline looks to be tapering off all
that to say all that to say that we have
just really seen a flattening out of
this trend it's not picking back up yet
but there are reasons to believe that
that could be happening when we look at
some of the other data now earlier this
week we got the nahb housing market
index and housing starts data both of
those reports came in much stronger than
expected want to put up here on your
screen the nahb housing market index
that came in this past month beating
expectations and the trends you see on
your screen now is that index and that's
the intimate in an index of sentiment as
well as sales and for and it factors in
new home sales a lot more but this is
really about home builders right or
folks going out building more homes are
they excited to build homes and as you
can see there there is a clear pickup
and we've seen it since the start of
this year every month you've seen since
the start of this year that index has
picked up and now we're back at the
highest level that we have seen on that
index since May of 2022 you also have
seen new home sales start to pick up and
this is why maybe you could start seeing
a bit of a Renaissance in the housing
market if this trend starts to pick up
and this chart just really illustrating
that beat that Rising sentiment that
we've seen so far this year in the
housing market in terms of especially
that new home sales Market housing
starts we're actually expected to
decline but Rose by 22 percent so a huge
increase in the number of houses and the
number of houses that are going to be
built contracts are laid out there and
folks saying okay we're going to go out
and build a new house those Jump by 22
percent last month expected to decline
and we got instead of reversal so we
look at the new home sales up about 12
uh year over year and about four percent
on the month uh 683 000 homes so it's
that gives you an idea of the scale uh
only about 700 new homes sold compared
to 4.3 million existing homes sold that
shows you there's a lot more new or a
lot more existing homes excuse me than
new homes to be sold we look at April's
big month over month gain that's
evidence that this construction of new
homes is really starting to pick up but
that's largely because there's just very
little inventory inventory is still at
historic lows in the existing housing
market uh the sale of new homes is about
seven and a half months so you got about
seven and a half months of the normal
pace of sales for new homes for existing
homes it's at just 3 months and to give
you an idea of historically where that
is that number of existing homes Supply
peaked at about 12 months of Supply back
in 2010 so in 2010 we're coming off the
you know the 2008 Global financial
crisis which was set off by the mortgage
Market crisis and the big you know bust
you had there and really a lot of homes
were being listed and put on the market
and there weren't a lot of buyers well
we had a record low of 1.7 months of
Supply in January of 2022 that's the low
so we're up from the low at three months
right now but still very far away from
that high of 12 months of Supply that we
saw in 2010
and really between 2010 and 2022 you
just saw that market just kind of
decline in terms of the amount of months
of Supply on the market that just really
kind of fell and we got from that 12
number to that 1.7 number basically two
months of Supply on the market we are
seeing a continued trend of higher uh
housing sales on the new home side uh
but we are not seeing that on the use on
the existing home side we're seeing it
flattening out Nar the National
Association of Realtors Chief Economist
Lawrence Yoon said something I thought
was really interesting in today's
existing home sales report he said quote
newly constructed homes are selling at a
pace reminiscent of pre-pandemic times
because of abundant inventory in that
sector however existing home sales
activity is down sizably due to the
current Supply being roughly half of the
level of 2019. so really what we're
seeing is a problem of Supply not enough
Supply but still lots of demand that's
not what the FED wants the FED wants to
reduce demand the fed's goal is to make
you and I people who might want to go
out and buy a home say you know what man
I want to buy a house but this you know
these rates are too high oh it's going
to cost me so much money to go out and
get a mortgage I'd rather not I'd rather
just rent you know or stay in my current
place where I am well that doesn't seem
to be happening there still is a lot of
demand out there for housing and there's
just not supplies so folks are still
going out looking they're still on
Zillow they're still scrolling they're
still going out and you know hitting
those uh those open houses and things
like that but they're just not buying
because they're not finding anything
that is in their price range or that
they like or that they can afford
because you know rates are so high but
also home prices are still high we're
down 3.1 percent from what was near
record highs a year ago so again we're
still seeing all the problems that were
existing in the housing market continue
and now we're starting to see those
existing home sales level off and not
fall anymore that could play a big role
in overall inflation so when we talk
about inflation we've got to take a look
at the CPI the Consumer Price Index want
to put that chart up here on your screen
right now so when you're talking about
the trend and that's that's what always
matters you see there from the beginning
of 2021 and I wanted to compare this to
that existing home sales chart that I
showed you before it just Rises up and
then since that peak in the middle of
2022 you see there on your screen
inflation has just continued to come
down it's consistently declined every
month really since then and you see that
nice wave pattern down that's not what
you see from the existing home sales
report that's showing it comes down but
then it picks up again and now we're
plateauing at that higher level I wanted
to just show the CPI chart to illustrate
the way that inflation has moved and how
that's different from overall existing
home sales housing is the biggest
component of core CPI which is held
above uh three percent or held above
five percent excuse me housing is about
40 percent of that core CPI number that
the FED watches so really this is
telling us right now that inflation
while it's been coming down consistently
the trend that we are seeing in home
sales is not going along with that and
falling as well and we could be be
seeing a leading indicator of inflation
stalling out or maybe even picking back
up if inflation follows that nahb
housing market index that I showed you
just a little bit earlier things to
watch out for however our real-time
indicators are telling us that rent
prices are going down core logic showed
single family rent slowed to only a gain
of 3.7 percent year over year now in
April that that tells you it's still
Rising rent is still Rising according to
core logic but that's down from about 14
increases at the same time in 2022.
um all U.S metros in the CoreLogic
survey posted an increase of just single
digits or less so that shows you that
the inflation is coming down in rents
except for Las Vegas that was the one
which posted a small annual loss
rent.com survey actually showed a
negative 0.57 percent drop in annual
prices so we are seeing rents decline
but again as housing prices go up and as
those rates stay high landlords owners
are going to have to pay more and
they're going to pass that cost on to
tenants renters etc etc and so we could
start to see those rental prices
continuing to pick back up now what I
want to do right now is let's take a
look at the markets I want to throw this
up here on your screen and just show you
what we're looking at in the markets
right now this is an overview of what
we're looking at on wsj.com
you see the Dow is down about 0.2
percent the s p about flat on the day
the NASDAQ holding up about half a
percent I thought what was really
interesting is crude you're seeing here
is down about five percent gold is down
about one percent so we've got some
interesting moves going on in the market
I think you saw a big pickup when you
look up here at the NASDAQ and some of
these other stock indexes that you were
seeing computers run a little slow
apologize for that but you did see a
pickup right around that 10 o'clock
number with this number of existing home
sales and really it seems like the
market is just kind of bullishly moving
upward and this just illustrating the
kind of trends that we have seen and are
seeing from the market especially stocks
which seem to be biased to move to the
website it'll be interesting to see
where we end today because the NASDAQ up
over 30 year to date we are seeing some
very interesting things in terms of the
market so listen let's talk about big
picture takeaways from this report Big
Picture takeaway number one don't be
fooled by the headlines you're going to
see folks and I've already seen this
biggest annual drop in prices since
2011. oh my gosh the how housing market
is falling off a cliff don't believe the
hype I'm telling you right now it's just
a 3.1 percent drop it's the biggest drop
that we've seen since 2011 because
mostly housing prices just go up so it's
unusual for them to go down but that
decrease you're seeing not a major
decrease not anything that anyone is
really going to get excited about
especially with mortgage rates still
around seven percent uh the pace of home
sales is lower than recent history but
it is not falling off a cliff we are not
seeing home sales cooperating with what
the FED wants to do we are not seeing a
decline in demand last but not least I
think the biggest surprise in the report
was that it just shows how strong the
demand for housing is price is still
near record highs rates have doubled
since 2021 but sales are not falling
this could be bad news for what the FED
wants to do on inflation because we know
they watch that core number we know that
core CPI course pce those two big
inflation gauges that the FED watches
and talks about are very tied to what's
going on in the housing market and very
tied to what's going on with how people
are paying for shelter here what comes
next well we are going to be right here
on Market takes 10 a.m Eastern on Monday
morning I hope you'll be with us for
that next week we'll be talking about
the new home sales report I think that's
going to be big does it continue to show
this trend of much higher sales much
higher prices and what does that tell us
about inflation also the pce report
which has been you know hasn't really
been in the news that much we've been
talking about CPI but I think this pce
report will be very interesting because
it's going to tell us you know where is
the fed's favorite gauge of inflation
moving it actually Rose last month while
CPI continued that decline that I showed
you on your screen so if pce rises again
that could really be big news to the FED
I'll tell you all about that on Monday
at 10 A.M listen that's going to do it
for us here on Market takes we will be
back with you Monday at 10 A.M Eastern I
hope you'll be with us and we will see
you next time